-Mississippi Senator
Cindy Hyde-Smith
made a campaign stop recently.
While she was there,
one of her supporters
said a lot of nice things
about her,
and in response, she said,
"If he invited me
to a public hanging,
I'd be on the front row,"
which many took
to be a reference to lynching.
Now, of course,
it's not appropriate
for a public official or anyone
to make a joke about lynching,
so here to comment is one of
our writers, Amber Ruffin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All aboard!
-Amber, what are you doing?
-I'm driving the train.
-And what train is that?
-The Redemption Train!
Now, sometimes, public officials
say crazy, racist things,
but that doesn't mean
they can't get back on track.
So, all aboard
the Redemption Train!
[ Train horn toots ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
All you have to do
is release a statement
that says, "I'm sorry."
So Cindy Hyde-Smith
released one that said,
"Any attempt to turn this into
a negative connotation
is ridiculous."
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Not exactly an apology,
but she can still keep
the redemption train on track
by holding a press conference
where she acts really sorry.
Take it away, Senator!
-We put out
a statement yesterday,
and we stand by that statement.
-Mm.
Try again.
-We put out
this statement yesterday,
and it's available,
and we stand by that statement.
-N-Not quite.
-We made a statement yesterday,
and we stand by the statement,
and that's all
I'm going to say about it.
-Repeat after me --
I'm sorry.
-I put out
a statement yesterday,
and that's all
I'm gonna say about it.
-Uh-oh, this is not going great.
We're overheating.
Someone needs to do something.
Get the governor!
-I can tell you,
all of us in public life
have said things on occasion
that we
could have phrased better.
When you make as many speeches
as we do in public life,
that does occur.
-Hey, that's a great point.
-I know this woman,
and I know her heart.
I knew it when I appointed her.
I know it now.
She meant no offense
by that statement.
-Nothing but
smooth sailing ahead.
-Brought the President of
the United States here
to open the Civil Rights Museum.
And African-American leadership
that would fail
to even come to the event
because the President of
the United States was there.
-Uh-oh. I would not bring up
Donald Trump right now.
[ Laughter ]
We're going off the rails here.
This could not get any worse.
-Today, I talked about
the genocide
of over 20 million
African-American children.
-Why's this man
talking about dead black kids?!
-See, in my heart,
I am confused about
where the outrage is at,
about 20 million
African-American children
that have been aborted.
No one wants
to say anything about that.
No one wants to talk about that.
-What the [bleep] is he
talking about abortion for?!
-What the hell
is going on up here?!
-He's trying
to make it about abortion!
-This train is going to explode!
-You think I don't know that?!
I'm doing everything I can!
Senator, save us!
-I put out
a statement yesterday.
A statement yesterday.
A statement.
Statement.
Statement yesterday.
-Stop saying that!
-We have to fix this!
-We can't!
-What about her career?!
-She's a white lady
from Mississippi!
She'll be fine!
Save yourself!
-I'm gonna jump!
Aaaaah!!
[ Explosion ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sometimes, not even the
Redemption Train can save you.
Unh!
[ Laughter ]
-She's gone.